- [Interviewer] All
right, Jason and Tasha.
Jason and Tasha where are you guys from?
- [Jason] Missouri.
- [Tasha] We're from Missouri.
- [Interviewer] And you guys are married?
- [Tasha] No, we were
together for four years.
We're pretty much married.
- [Interviewer] Then, tell
me about how you grew up.
Jason.
- I grew up with a biker as a father,
and mom wasn't around,
when I didn't meet her.
We were doing drugs immediately.
So I grew up in a environment
where drugs were accepted
and passed around as children.
So we grew up kind of fast.
- [Interviewer] So drugs
came into your life-
- Really early, about 13
years old, I was doing drugs.
- [Interviewer] What kind of stuff?
- Like heroin was my first addiction.
Yeah, was well strong
opiates, morphine, Oxycontin.
And then it switched to heroin
later on when I ran out.
But-
- [Interviewer] And how would
you describe your childhood?
- Traumatic.
Yeah.
- [Interviewer] What kind
of stuff was going on?
- Violence.
Like a lot of violence, a lot of drugs,
a lot of in and out of state custody
and kidnappings and stuff so.
- [Interviewer] And
Tasha, tell me about your,
how you grew up
- Pretty much had the same type of family.
Dad wasn't around mom wasn't
really around much either.
Went to Kansas for a while.
Being,
I was emancipated.
I started cooking drugs
before I did drugs.
I was making drugs at six years old
and I didn't start doing
drugs since I was almost 30.
And then when I did do
drugs, I was spent hard on.
Real hard.
It was mainly
it was everything I would do
would have to be in a needle.
It wasn't in a needle.
I wasn't gonna do it.
I raised my brother.
- [Interviewer] How was,
how was your childhood?
Any traumatic events?
- Yeah, it was, yeah.
Real traumatic events.
Being in a biker family being a girl
isn't all that it seems it should be.
It's nearly not that.
It's ain't fun.
You think it's fun at the
time, but it's not fun.
- [Interviewer] So abuse of what sort?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Violent?
- [Interviewer] Sexual abuse?
- Yeah my ex-husband had me kidnapped.
He kidnapped me and kept me secluded
from my family for three years.
I couldn't talk to them.
I had two kids in that time
who they didn't get to see.
And then they finally got to see later on.
- [Interviewer] How far
do you guys go in school?
- I ended up getting my high
school equivalency in prison
but I made it in school to ninth grade.
- [Interviewer] Ninth grade?
- Yeah.
- Same here, ninth grade.
- [Interviewer] Ninth grade.
- First day, ninth grade.
- [Interviewer] And
then you guys met, how?
- He took my job.
- Yeah, I took her job as
a manager at a call center
and we're doing really
well, got a house, a car-
- Nice house, had my kids.
- Yeah, we were doing well, and then
an event took place in the front
yard of our house and ended
up losing my job, my house, my
ID, everything at that point.
- Kids.
- So we decided to go on
vacation to California.
Boom!
Came out here.
And once we came out
to California the series
of unfortunate events
just continued like cascaded
into a year on Skid row.
- [Interviewer] So tell me
about your year on Skid row.
- [Tasha] Mine, I enjoyed it.
I, actually did.
I didn't have,
I stayed at the rescue mission
for about three months.
Union rescue mission.
- [Interviewer] Union rescue
mission is one of the big,
bigger missions here.
- [Tasha] Yeah, right
there on Skid row yeah.
And then I went from there
when the COVID came out
I got me a tent and sat
up on third and main.
And that was crazy.
That,
that was crazy.
And then they figured a hotel for a while.
I was there for about two
months, till you got here
and then once he got here,
I forfeited the hotel.
Cause he couldn't stay there me.
- [Jason] I got here and
the homeless had taken over,
not Grand park.
- [Tasha] Except for riots.
- [Jason] But the park,
What is it, Central park?
- [Tasha] Grand beach, Grand park.
- [Jason] Grand park.
A black lives matter group had taken
over that park entirely.
It was like living there.
And there were riots every
night, like helicopters
with spotlights and
goon squad up and down the streets.
It was crazy.
- [Tasha] It was in the
LA Times, front page.
- [Jason] I got my jaw shattered
the first day I was here.
I lost track of her and
was lost in downtown
like three in the morning
I'm yelling for her,
and like out of nowhere I get surrounded
like kicked up off the ground
by a horseshoe bike lock
hits me right in my jaw.
- [Interviewer] So who shattered your jaw?
- [Jason] Some really,
really huge black dudes.
(laughing)
Like it's three buddies, but like, yeah.
- [Interviewer] And was there
something you were doing that?
- No, no.
- He was at third and main
- I was just looking, looking
like I had a little bit
of money
- Yelling for me.
- And yelling for her
at three in the morning.
- Where I used to stay.
- Yeah I was completely oblivious
to the fact that I was in the projects
running around screaming
for my white girlfriend.
(laughing)
And then I was like, yeah
like I now looking back,
I know it was ridiculous.
- [Interviewer] So you guys,
you guys lived in a tent?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] I just found
you at the Greyhound station.
You're getting ready
to go back to Missouri.
- Yeah, you found us on the last day
of our craziest adventure
we've ever been on.
- [Interviewer] What kind
of stuff have you seen
in your time here?
- Oh man, we have saved,
several people's lives.
- I have saved people's lives.
- Seen several people die.
- I seen this dead lady in
this tent all screwed up
looking like this and some
dude doing some voodoo stuff.
It was,
wild.
She was old.
I mean, she was been dead for awhile,
for a long while.
- Yeah.
- It was creepy.
- You see things out here.
They're like, they're
not even human anymore.
They don't even don't-
- That chick that was
slamming her head on the tree?
- Yeah.
There was this chick.
She was just completely possessed
to a point where she didn't feel no
no real pain at all.
She's slapping her head off this tree.
- And you just hear-
- Yeah.
- And there's laughing.
- Sickening thud every
time she slaps her head
off this tree and then she just laughs
and like rips chunk of her hair out.
And-
- Right in front of our tent.
- Yeah, I'm like what in the hell?
- And I tried to grab my clothes.
- And she's like 20 years
old and kind of pretty,
ad you're just like.
- Like what happened?
- I'm like what happened to you?
- But then months later she was normal.
- Yeah, completely normal.
Like it was never happening.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] So what
drugs do you guys play
around with now?
- Well I play around just a
little bit of anything, but.
- I just do meth and I smoke lots of weed,
- I smoke tons of weed.
- Lots of weed.
- [Interviewer] And how do
you guys support yourself?
- Pretty much out here.
It's through little, little
bit of selling of drugs
by enough to where I can
sell a little bit and pay
for my addiction really
and that's about it.
Everything else gets fed to us.
- [Interviewer] And Tasha,
are you doing what a lot
of the ladies do sometimes?
- Yeah, I just I sell drags a lot.
Meth out here is like cash.
If you got meth you can
have anything you want.
- [Interviewer] No but
what I was referring to is
do you date guys for money?
- No.
- [Interviewer] You don't?
- Everybody thinks that she does though.
Yeah I know.
- The way I dress.
- And she chooses to dress like this too.
- This is like calm compared
to what I usually wear.
- It gets me in a lot of fights.
(laughing)
- Yeah.
- I like to dress creative.
- [Interviewer] Do
either of you have kids?
- Yeah, we both do.
- Yeah, I've got three kids.
- I've got two.
- But none together.
- I've got two, none together though.
- [Interviewer] None together?
- No.
- [Interviewer] And
who's raising your kids.
- My daughter's mom.
- And my kids are staying
with my stepmom and my dad.
- [Interviewer] And so, yeah,
So you'll go back to Missouri and do what?
- I'm going back to see my kids.
Yeah, I'm going back to see
my father before he dies.
Actually he's in a retirement home
even though we had a rough childhood
he's still my hero and he was a great man.
So I just don't, I don't blame him
for it because I don't
think he knew any better.
I just think it was just
he was a product of his environment.
- [Interviewer] You have to
understand that these people
that we all see as guilty,
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Probably went through
something equally bad or worse?
- Exactly, exactly.
- Or worse yeah.
- Cause, if I was to be mad at him
then I'd have to be mad at
myself too, because I did
I've done the same thing to my daughter.
- [Interviewer] Forgiveness is the answer.
What was the most important
lesson you guys have learned?
- Don't take anything for granted.
Don't have value on things.
- Don't get caught up on material things.
- And possessions.
- Cause material things,
aren't what matters.
- It isn't.
- It's not what you got it's who you got.
- And your word.
And we say "you going do something
and so you're gonna do
something make sure you go
through with it."
You know
- Yup.
I've had some of the best
times of my life out here
on Skid row and definitely
had some of the worst.
- If somebody needs
something and you got it,
give it to him, man.
If you can give it to him give it him man.
- There are some of the coolest,
realest, nicest people out here.
- Really.
- For real, they will do anything for you.
- But at the same time there's
people there that would-
- They'll play the role.
- And take everything you got.
- Yeah.
And kick you in the nuts.
( interviewer laughing)
- We've had our tent burn down twice.
- Yeah.
- I had mine ripped apart
by the protestors and pee
thrown at me and spit on.
Cause I was white.
I was on third main.
- [Interviewer] How was
your year here changed you?
- My jaw is shaped a little different now.
(laughing)
- I'm a little bit more bossy.
I'm really independent now I
know if I could make it here
in California and on Skid
row so I can be anywhere.
- Now when people approach me,
I'm not necessarily so nice
at first I used to
welcome anybody.
Like I wanted to talk to anybody.
I was a salesman and
that's what I love to do,
I'd talk to anybody.
Now when people approach me I'm like,
- "what do you want?"
- Yeah.
Like "step back,
give me six feet or I'm
going to freak out."
What the hell do you want?
- He doesn't quite like the
way I dress so much anymore.
- It messed me up.
It was a traumatic experience.
Getting my teeth knocked out like that.
I didn't even go to the
hospital for my jaw.
I was too scared.
I was like, "nope".
I fell asleep that night
wrapped around a bush up front
of the hospital because I
went to go into the hospital
and like when I walked
through the door, I'm like
I'm covering my mouth and-
Cause this is before
face masks were real bad
and I'm covering my mouth.
And I was like, they're
like, "can we help you?"
I'm like,
"I gotta go get my wife
out of the car real quick."
And I ran back out and
hid around a bush and
I still hadn't even found
her until the next day
when I walked like four
miles still completely lost.
Fuckin',
yeah.
- That was actually where I took him.
- Yeah I was like four blocks from
where I was supposed to be.
But in LA that's a big deal
especially when you're not from here.
I had no idea where I was.
It was horrible.
It definitely put up all
shields.
- Relationships don't
really last out here.
- I was like red alert to the fullest.
No new relationships don't
really last on Skid row.
- People give us crap all
the time like cause we fight.
- Everybody, everybody hates the fact that
we're together because
nobody has a lasting
relationship out here, they're
just pass roaming around.
- With a faithful girlfriend.
- [Interviewer] I think once drugs become
part of the picture
your priorities change.
- Yeah absolutely.
- I was gonna say the same.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- We're faithful to each other.
- [Interviewer] It's
remarkable that you guys are
stayed together.
- Yeah, yeah.
- I love him.
- Both of us have already been conquered
by drugs once and like kind of now,
now we just use drugs
because that's literally
what we've always done.
It's a form of self-medicating,
but really I can't function
unless I do use drugs to at
least a small extent I've used
at least a little bit of drugs or else
then I'm not able to function.
Like, I don't know,
I've always worked a good
job and been on drugs.
Like, I mean, to some extent.
Of course every time I get
too far out there on drugs,
I lose my job and everything, but.
- I quit doing drugs for a whole lot.
- Yeah, Yeah.
Both of us do.
We'll quit using the drug
if we, if we start using it too much
we'll stop for a little while.
And it's always at different times too.
So it's really weird the
way, the way it works.
Well then just quit shooting up.
She quit like five months ago.
Yeah.
- We're only still doing it
and I'm like, "Nope, I'm done."
I don't wanna do like that no more.
I'll smoke it down but.
- [Interviewer] Do you guys feel like your
the childhood environments
or the families you grew
up in kind of
- I grantee it.
- Absolutely.
- [Interviewer] Put you
where you are today?
- Yeah.
- [Jason] Shaped us for it
because there's, there's no way
a normal person is going
to get just dropped
off out here and be okay.
There's no way.
- [Tasha] You can make
Skid row being a female,
a white female by yourself
and sell drugs and live where I lived.
It's, I'm surprised.
Everything bad that's happened to me.
- [Jason] I've had a fight like four
or five times in one day
before because of it.
- [Tasha] Because of me.
- [Jason] Yeah, because
her, yeah, it's ridiculous.
- [Interviewer] All right you guys,
I'll take you back to the bus station.
- [Tasha] All right.
- [Jason] All right cool.
- [Interviewer] Where
you can get your bus.
Thank you so much.
- Yeah.
- Thank you.